this is gonna make some of you very
angry but uh I never thought of Pluto as
a planet historically speaking though it
wasn't even the first planet to be
reclassified back in ancient Greece the
sun and moon were considered planets the
word Planet just meant Wanderer it was
any object that wandered against the
background Stars but eventually we
discovered asteroids and comets and
stuff and we came up with specific names
for those we never really had a good
scientific definition for planet for a
while the definition was just these nine
objects for some reason it's not very
scientific so in 2006 we came up with a
better definition it has to orbit the
sun it has to be roughly spherical and
it has to have cleared its orbit of
similar sized objects as far as I'm
concerned Pluto is just a big Comet but
I'm fine with the dwarf planet
compromise at least it's consistent